[Musique]
c'est notre projet c'est d'écart poudre
ça veut dire non pour le covoiturage
l'idée du projet c'est faire une
connexion entre deux voitures
à de façon à avoir une caméra installée
sur une des deux voitures qui détecte la
plaque d'immatriculation de l'autre
voiture et on voit un message
personnalisé à la voiture destinataire
j'avais cette idée à cause d'un incident
qui m'est arrivé une fois j'étais en
train de conduire et j'avais les
écouteurs dans les oreilles et j'avais
les fermer les fenêtres fermées je sais
que c'est interdit la en france mais au
niveau 7 c'est pas interdit ce moment
alors j'ai regardé le rétroviseur et
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un qui me fait le
droit de l'arrière elle était vraiment
fâché après j'ai constaté qu'il était en
train de me clocks on est tout le temps
et moi j'ai comme j'avais les écouteurs
dans les oreilles j'ai pas entendu alors
j'étais comme dans une situation d' un
malentendant je me suis dit pourquoi il
n'y avait pas un moyen pour qu'il puisse
me contacter directement
ah si j'ai pas fait attention
cette idée sera très utile pour les
personnes malentendantes
parce que par exemple on a fait une
recherché n'a trouvé que dans 60 pays
c'est interdit aux malentendants de deux
conduisent le projet c'était dans le
contexte du hac at on lancé par nokia
aux poteaux 204 sas a fait part du de
nantis les études en masse à m dos et il
s'était en fait le projet de fin de
l'année pour valider le master nous
devons présenter ce projet et j'avais la
chance d'être accepté de
travailler sur ce projet et ça s'est
bien passé nous nous envisageons d'avoir
un financier par exemple les
fabricateurs de des voitures comme
renault qui vont intégrer ce système
dans la fabrication des nouvelles
voitures à pour qu'elle soit utilisée
sur le terrain
[Musique]